what's going on guys
Pixar they're at it again finding dory
is hitting theaters and we have set out
with the monumental task of finding out
what is the greatest Pixar film of all
time and we have an esteemed panel of
film critics and cinema minds to help us
out first you know I'm from schmoes know
you know from Collider movie talk he's
also very funny stand-up comedian Mark
Ellis you know this woman from screen
junkies Plus and Fandango among other
places welcome back Alesha Malone and AH
you know I'm you love them the movie
fights champion and the host of summer
movie report Dan Merle before we jump in
let me tell you how we broke down our
bracket so finding Dory is not included
because that comes out this weekend we
have calculated a very complicated
algorithm that includes I am DB user
rankings box office results and rotten
tomato critic scores we threw that in a
blender and came out with 1 through 16
hey do it yourself
shall we begin let's do this the number
one film by our calculations Toy Story 3
versus the number 16 seed Cars 2 Mark
Ellis you know how I like cars too more
than most people did I actually join it
for what it was but it's nowhere near
the level of Toy Story 3 oh yes 3 ok
that's one for Toy Story 3
Alicia Malone definitely Toy Story 3 toy
story 3 moves on Dan your vote is moot
but what would you have said my choice 3
3 obviously our number 9 seed wall-e vs.
our number 8 seed The Incredibles you
know what let's not do this I'm kidding
we're doing this Dan we're gonna start
with you I think the Incredibles people
don't give it as much credit now because
we didn't have the kind of superhero
stuff when The Incredibles came out that
we have now wall-e is like a visual
poetry this is a coin toss for me it's
like 5149 wall-e
so it's 100 wall-e Marc Ellis I love The
Incredibles one of my favorite Pixar one
of my favorite movies
given the big edge to the Incredibles we
are all knotted at one apiece The
Incredibles wall-e can you stand this
Alicia Malone wall-e it was really
revolutionary a robot film showing a
great story about love the destruction
of planet future of humanity and then
the Incredibles he's one of my favorite
superhero films I'm gonna go with Wally
Wow Wow
gets the edge for me wall-e here's a
thumbs down annexed Toy Story 2 vs cars
we're going to start with Alicia I'm
alone
well cause isn't one of my favorite
Pixar film Toy Story 2 was supposed to
be a direct-to-dvd sequel and then they
put it in theatrical release because it
was so good Toy Story 2 for me that's an
easy choice boom 1 for Toy Story 2 Mark
Ellis I think Alicia is right I think
the Toy Story proved that not only is
this movie series a good franchise it is
now a dynasty thanks to Toy Story 2 I'm
giving it the easy win over cars boom
Toy Story 2 Dan toys sorted yeah whoo
okay yeah I don't know why I made that
noise this is not a difficult choice for
me the number five seed inside out
against monsters University let's start
with Dan Merle Mazda university gets a
bad rap it gets lumped in with the cars
twos of the Pixar thing I don't think
that it's necessarily a terrible movie
inside out is top 5 picks are transcends
being an animated film just a great film
I got to go inside up boom one oh inside
out Ellis you know inside out did
something incredible where did manage to
feel so original and funny and
heartwarming all in the same movie
whereas I can't even remember the other
movie it's going up against which is why
inside out gets the easy vicar Alicia
agree I totally agree with that
Finding Nemo the number 2 is going up
against the good dinosaur could it be
the great dinosaur Alicia no I love 1o
Finding Nemo Dan Merle good dinosaur was
like a mid-90s DreamWorks level quality
animated no it was very shots fired
Nemo is far superior the number-10 film
ratatouille versus the number seven
ranked film on our list Oh LS I love the
little rat I love what he's trying to do
it's the ultimate underdog story however
up managed to do something I didn't
think a film could do where it ripped my
heart out and showed it to us in the
first five minutes I'm giving the win to
the seventh seed up BAM that's one for
up Dan Merle I think that people confuse
up with the first ten minutes of them
it's hard to beat that first ten minutes
about but yeah at the totality of the
movie yes I give the edge to ratatouille
Wow I don't often cry in movies that
montage absolutely killed me yeah but I
agree with Dan that the rest of the
movie wasn't as good as the first ten
minutes so I'm gonna go with ratatouille
yeah we're gonna have to go into hiding
after this I know it's Pixar's fault
they made too many good movies
the next first-round matchup is Toy
Story versus brave Alicia let's start
with you yeah I mean I like that female
character and brave but much like a good
dinosaur brave to me doesn't feel like a
Pixar film it feels like a Disney
Princess film it also feels like a bit
of a DreamWorks film it's got this crazy
slapstick humor that I felt out of place
with the whole movie
so Toy Story is definitely my choice
let's go to mark Ellis it's impossible
to vote against Pixar's rookie card I'm
going to star in a very easy victory BAM
Toy Story the og moving on Dan any
thoughts suet sanity beyond all right
our final matchup of the first round the
number 11 seed a bug's life vs. Monsters
Inc let's start with Dan Moreau I think
bug's life falling Toy Story they're
still kind of tweaking the formula a
little bit I think by the time they got
to Monsters Inc a few years later they
kind of figured out how the moving
pieces work I'm gonna give it to
Monsters Inc let's move over to Mark
Ellis there's no way that Monsters Inc
is gonna lose to a bug's life a bug's
life squashed by Monsters Inc alright
the second round
is set these are all Sophie's choices
the number one seed
Toy Story 3 versus our number 9 seed
wall-e Alicia Malone they're both
inventive in their own way but I am just
gonna give the edge to Toy Story 3 100
Toy Story 3 / wall-e Dan Merle they say
vote with your heart and I think that
more than any other movie I Toy Story 3
just spoke to me on a personal level
we've all been kids we all had toys
we've all grown up halfway wall-e great
movie but personally I got to go with
Toy Story 3 BAM that means Toy Story 3
moving on sends wall-e straight to the
furnace next second round match up folks
Toy Story 2 vs. inside out Mark Ellis I
would have to give the edge the slight
edge is something that just again felt
so funny and original and creative
I'm gonna go surprising myself with
inside out
Alicia Malone and I was just saying that
I love the Toy Story universe but inside
out what we was able to do you know talk
about emotions make you feel all these
emotions
bing-bong oh my god so that's why I'm
going inside out Jess she was kind to
Richard kind and bing-bong Richard kind
of voice of bing-bong inside out is
moving on ratatouille
vs. Finding Nemo Dan I would have said
ratatouille fairly easily up until a
while ago but I just re-watched Nemo and
it's really kind of grown on me it's
such a relatable story and I think that
they really bring depth to fish and I
can't overlook the technological advance
of that movie that movie looked unlike
any other computer animated movie before
the way they were able to do underwater
I got to go Nemo Finding Nemo 100 ver
ratatouille
Alicia Malone ratatouille tells us much
smaller story there's not that much at
stake brilliant movie but I've got to go
also with Finding Nemo there you go
Finding Nemo any thoughts ratatouille
sleeps with the fishes tonight yes the
number three seed Toy Story versus the
number six seed Monsters Inc Mark Ellis
my god this is tough because I really
fell in love with Mike and Sulley when I
saw monsters and Chris the idea of that
feels so fun and and it gets kids into
monsters but it doesn't scare them so it
did something really tough but I can't
sell short the greatness of the very
first Toy Story it's one of the reasons
why we get to debate these lists at all
great that's 104 Toy Story Dan Merle
Monsters Inc I enjoy but Toy Story no
one had ever seen anything like it
before it's a landmark not just in
animation but in but in film its itself
and and I think people forget Tom Hanks
and Tim Allen are fantastic I love that
that that note I love that character
that he plays I got a go toy store BAM
Alicia agree yeah sorry Toy Story moving
on to the final four and that means our
final four is set Wow up first Toy Story
three the number one seed versus inside
out the number five seed Alicia Malone
Toy Story 3 is my favorite of the bunch
of the three have to go with Toy Story 3
it's really hard though that's like a
slight edge let's check in with Dan
Merle this is the Battle of the movies
that are going to have me in tears by
the end of it inside out did things
narrative Lee that I could not believe
that they were doing with a kids movie
and what it says about human nature and
the fact that happiness and sadness are
things that everybody needs in
conjunction like I that movie totally
blew me away I have to go inside out and
I can't fault you for that and that
locks us up at 1:1 Toy Story 3 and
inside out it comes down to mr. Marc
Ellis to make a choice the win that I'm
going to have to give to the movie that
has a villain presence that the other
one lacks I love Ned Beatty as that
scary purple teddy bear and so I'm going
to give toys Story 3 the W Toy Story 3
moving on to the finals our second
matchup of the final four
Finding Nemo the number 2 seed versus
Toy Story the number 3 seed
Alysha Finding Nemo I think was was so
revolutionary at the time but Toy Story
set the bar high for what animation
could do as well as you were saying
earlier Dan films in general made me
feel a lot of things Toy Story all right
let's see if this Schmo knows which of
these films he prefers you know I don't
know that I'm going to be able to resist
a Captain America Civil War all-out
brawl in the final between the toys of
Toy Story and the toys of Toy Story 3
but then I start considering Finding
Nemo and how much heart that movie had
and how it had two of my all-time
favorite comedians Albert Brooks and
Ellen DeGeneres they go on such an
amazing adventure that was visually
gorgeous like nothing I'd ever seen
before
I love you Toy Story but I'm gonna go
with Finding Nemo in an upset that I
couldn't even predict Wow okay so we are
at 1:1 Dan Merle Toy Story was the first
you got the strong cast you've got the
fact that no one had done this before
Nemo you have I think a more heartfelt
story and I think that's an important
aspect it may not be fair but I think
these movies are pretty equal and I
think I think that Woody and Buzz
already have their day in court so I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna give it to
Nemo Nemo swims into the finals
we have ended up with our number one
seed Toy Story 3 versus our number 2
seed Finding Nemo Mark Ellis
I love the adorable fish he's got a
great voice nothing is going to be Toy
Story 3 in this tournament or a lot of
other ones Toy Story 3 goes up early BAM
a definitive choice from Mark Ellis
Alicia oh yeah Finding Nemo as you're
saying really emotional story plus it
pushed the boundaries with computer
animation Toy Story 3 though is my
favorite Pixar film I love how it
completes the story it is an adventure
within itself
but it's a hot toys but Toy Story 3 is
absolutely incorrect there you have it
Dan do you sign off on that
make it unanimous Toy Story 3 Toy Story
3 the number one Pixar film of all time
you did it you did it how do you feel
after that you got Boston yeah oh my god
that was a workout what did you think of
our bracket our tournament and the
winner Toy Story 3 who would you have
chosen what was the biggest up
who didn't move on that should've let us
know in the comment section below
best answer we're gonna send you a
screen junkies t-shirt I got to thank
this awesome panel that was fun and you
guys did the damn thing Mark Ellis
Alicia Malone Dan Merle I'm Hal Rudnick
I want to thank you for watching and hit
me up on Twitter bye bye
fall in love with and quickly get sick
of Dori the fish version of the kid who
asked their parents what's happening
every five seconds we going in there can
I help you you mean like a party is it
your dad or my dad where are you going
you okay what's the matter what's wrong
hey what you doing it's cool I'm lost
the mask where'd you drop it Duke
Proctor